order order if we have to go on longer
because people sitting on the trencher
event are yelling to try to disrupt
Superior Labour Party led by Jeremy
Corbyn yeah you know we don't name
people in the chamber people must
observe the rules no order order order I
am simply and politely informing the
prime minister of the very long
established procedure with which
everybody including the Prime Minister
must comply leave me to control the
proceedings doctor need any help from
anybody judging represent reposition if
they have their way whole sectors of the
economy or order or order that really is
very very unseemly there is a procedure
to statements of this kind a very long
established procedure and I'm setting
out the position and no one be he ever
so high is gonna tell me what the
procedures in the chamber of the House
of Commons I know exactly what the
situation is and I've got very much more
experience with these matters than some
of the people who think that they can
criticize order I think the Chancellor
of the Duchy that when he turns up at
our children's school as a parent he's a
very well behaved fellow spare us the
theatrics behave yourself
[Applause]
[Music]